[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: It is my very honor to
welcome you, Tali, to Mountain
View here, to Google.
And it is my very
honor and pleasure
to introduce Tali to you guys
here in the room, a world
renowned researcher
and scientist
in the field of
cognitive neuroscience.
Tali investigates how
motivation and emotion determine
our expectations of the
future, our everyday decisions,
our memories, and
our ability to learn.
She's talking about her brand
new book, "The Influential
Mind."
And Tali shows us how to avoid
pitfalls in our daily struggle
to affect others.
Ladies and gentlemen, it is my
very honor and my very pleasure
to pass on the microphone
to Dr. Tali Sharot.
[CLAPPING]
TALI SHAROT: Thank you so much,
[? Minu, ?] for inviting me.
[? Minu ?] has been amazing
at organizing this, and also
at organizing a previous
talk and a conference
that he organized in Chicago.
So thank you so much.
And thank you all for coming
and watching wherever you are.
So as [? Minu ?] said, I am
a cognitive neuroscientist.
So that's basically
psychology and neuroscience
mixed together.
And I bring people
into my lab, and I
try to understand the brain
mechanisms that give rise
to how people act every day,
how they interact, how they
make decisions, how they think.
And "The Influential
Mind" is really about
how people form beliefs, how
belief can be quite stubborn,
but how change is possible if
we understand the human mind
and if we understand thinking.
And a lot of what I'm
going to talk about today
is how people
process information,
how they seek out
information, and how
they process information
to form those beliefs.
And so that's one
kind of point that
has a lot to do with what
you guys are doing here.
But I'm going to start
by exploring thinking.
And the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to do an
experiment with you guys here.
So I'm going to give
you three numbers.
And I want you to figure
out the rule that I
used to generate those numbers.
But for now just keep
it in your mind, OK.
Don't say anything.
So my numbers are
two, four, six.
OK.
Now, the way that
we're going to do it,
I'm going to give
you an opportunity
to give me three numbers.
And I will tell you if those
three numbers fit my rule
or do not fit my rule.
And then I'll let
you guess the rule.
OK.
So [? Minu, ?] I'm
going to start with you.
Give me three numbers,
and I will tell you
if they fit my rule
or not, and then I'll
let you guess the rule.
SPEAKER: I say it's 10 and 12.
TALI SHAROT: No.
three numbers you need.
SPEAKER: Three numbers?
TALI SHAROT: Yeah.
So I have a rule which I use
to generate these numbers.
What you need to do is
figure out what this rule is.
And the way that
we're going to do
it is I'll let you test it
by giving me three numbers,
and I'll tell you it
fits my rule or not.
So give me any three
numbers that you think.
And I'll tell you, does
it fit my rule or not?
And then I'll let
you guess the rule.
So.
SPEAKER: 12, 14, and 16?
TALI SHAROT: Yes.
If fits my rule.
Do you want to guess the rule?
SPEAKER: It is you're
always adding two up.
TALI SHAROT: OK.
No.
That's not the rule.
So we'll do one more.
Do you want to give
me three numbers?
AUDIENCE: 8, 10, 12.
TALI SHAROT: Yeah.
It fits my rule.
Do you want to guess a rule?
AUDIENCE: It starts with
a two and [INAUDIBLE] two.
TALI SHAROT: No.
No.
That's not my rule.
Now, I think you know the answer
because you're [INAUDIBLE]..
So I'll let you do it.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Even
numbers is the rule?
TALI SHAROT: No.
First of all, you have
to give me three numbers.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I'm sorry.
How about two, four--
can I give you the same numbers?
TALI SHAROT: Well, they
obviously fit my rule.
So you can.
But that--
AUDIENCE: It's not even numbers?
TALI SHAROT: No.
OK.
One last thing.
Give me three numbers
and then guess the rule.
Does anyone want to have a try?
Go ahead.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking like 8, 10, 12.
And I was thinking you
add a two [INAUDIBLE]..
TALI SHAROT: Yeah.
OK.
So it does [INAUDIBLE].
So my rule was simply
escalating numbers.
5, 10, 100 would be a yes.
Five, zero, one would be a no.
OK.
What's the point
of this experiment?
The point of this
experiment is to show you
that based on a very
limited set of data
we form strong beliefs and
hypotheses in our head,
and then automatically
what we try to do
is we try to confirm those
beliefs by seeking out
confirming evidence.
So many people here thought
that my rule was escalating even
numbers.
And so what you
automatically do is
you give me an example of
escalating even numbers.
So you say 8, 10, 12.
You're trying to
confirm that belief.
And what people don't
do is they don't
try to challenge those beliefs.
So another way to get
to the truth, if you
think it's escalating
even numbers,
would be to say
one, three, five.
And I would say,
yes, it fits my rule.
Then you would know that
your belief is wrong,
and you would get
to the truth faster.
So that's an example of what
we call the confirmation bias.
Now, this specific
example was first
shown by Peter Wason in 1960.
Peter was an academic in
my own department at UCL.
He passed away a few years
before I joined the department.
And the reason this
experiment is important
is not about numbers.
The reason it's important
is that we all host
a range of beliefs in our head.
We have beliefs about gender.
We have scientific theories
that we believe in.
We have beliefs about religion,
and beliefs about ourselves
and how our company should work,
and about our relationships
with our family
and our colleagues.
And what we tend to
do without knowing it
is that we go about our
day every single day trying
to find evidence that will
confirm and strengthen
those beliefs.
And rarely do we try to
challenge those beliefs.
But what happens when we do
encounter a piece of evidence
or an opinion that doesn't
quite fit what we believe in?
So we tested this question in
the domain of climate change.
So together with my colleagues
we conducted a study
where we wanted to see
whether we can change
people's opinions
about climate change
by giving them information.
Now, I'm not only
talking about those
who do not believe
in climate change,
but also those that do
believe in climate change.
Can we change their opinion
as well with information?
So the first thing we
did is we asked everyone,
do you believe in
made climate change?
Do you support the
Paris agreement?
And based on their
answers we divided them
into the strong believers
and the weak believers.
Next we asked them,
please estimate
by how much do you think
the temperature would
rise in the next 100 years.
So, unsurprisingly,
the weak believers
gave us an estimate
that was smaller
than the strong believers.
Then came the real test.
We told half of all
our participants
that the scientists have
re-evaluated the data
and they now concluded
that actually things
are not that bad.
It's not as bad as
they thought before.
And the temperature would rise
by only a tiny little bit.
We told the other half
of our participants
that the scientists have
re-evaluated the data,
and now have concluded the
situation is much, much worse
than they previously
thought, and the temperature
would rise by a very
significant amount.
And please, everyone give
us your new estimate.
So the question
was whether people
will change their estimate
based on this information
that we gave them.
And the answer was, yes,
as long as the information
fit their original worldview.
So when the weak believers heard
that the scientists are saying,
actually you made a mistake, and
the situation is not that bad
at all, they moved a
lot in that direction.
But they didn't
budge at all when
they heard that
the scientists are
saying things are actually
more dire than we originally
thought.
Now, the strong believers
showed the opposite.
So when they learned that
the scientists are saying,
actually things are much
better than we thought,
the situation is
not that bad, they
didn't move in that direction.
But when they learned
the scientists are saying
things are much worse
than we thought before,
they moved a lot
in that direction.
So this, again,
is another example
of the confirmation
bias, which is basically
when you give
people data they are
quick to take in the data that
fits their original worldview
but assess counter evidence
with a critical eye.
Now, this phenomena
is not new at all.
It's an old phenomena.
But now when information
is so readily accessible
it's having more of an
effect on our beliefs
because we can find
data, and information,
and evidence on the
web to support anything
that we want to believe in.
And so what's happening is that
groups are moving to extremes.
And so information can
actually cause polarization
instead of bringing people
together because of this bias.
So we wanted to know what goes
on inside the human brain when
people encounter opinions
or a piece of data that
doesn't really fit their view.
So the way that we did that is
we brought people into our lab
in pairs.
And we asked them to make
financial decisions together.
Specifically they had
to assess real estate.
And while they were doing
that we recorded their brain
activity in two MRI scanners,
but they could communicate
with each other over computers.
So the way that it works is
each person lies down like this.
And there's a little
head coil with a mirror.
And the mirror can
project anything
that we want from
a computer screen.
So we show people the questions.
We show them the opinion
of their partner.
And they put their answers
using the button box here.
And while we do that
we record their brain
activity using this method
that's called functional MRI.
So what we found
was when two people
agreed each person's
brain showed
precise encoding
of the information
given by the agreeing partner.
So what I'm showing you here
is a slice of the brain.
If I were to cut your brain
like this and then look inside,
and I'm highlighting all
the regions that we found
were encoding the
information coming
from an agreeing partner.
And what happened was when two
people agreed their confidence
in their own opinion and
their own decision went up.
So so far this is not
surprising, right?
If another person agrees
your confidence goes up.
However, when the two people
disagreed, metaphorically
speaking, it looks as if
the brain was shutting down,
and we couldn't find
evidence that it
was encoding the information
coming from a disagreeing
partner.
And what happened to
people's confidence
in their own decision?
It didn't change much.
There was only a
non-significant decrease.
So people were kind
of ignoring it.
Interestingly, sometimes we
blacked out the computer screen
so people couldn't see
what others were thinking.
Nevertheless, in those
situations people
also became more confident
in their own decision.
I can only assume that they were
thinking that the other person
is probably agreeing with them.
They just can't see it.
And they became
more confident too.
So many times when
people see this they
ask me, well, is this
true for everyone?
Is there individual differences?
Well, if you see yourself
as highly analytical, which
I think most people in this
room do, embrace yourself.
So a study conducted by
[? Don ?] [? Kahan ?] at Yale
University showed that people
with better math skills are
more likely to
twist data at will.
So he tested 1,000 Americans,
and the first thing he did
is he gave everyone
math questions
and analytical questions,
logic questions.
And based on those
questions he divided them
into those with high skills
and those with low skills.
And then he gave them
two sets of data.
The first set of
data he told them
was looking at whether skin
treatment was helping rashes.
And he said, OK,
look at the data.
Analyze the data.
And tell me if this
treatment is helping.
Unsurprisingly, those
with better math skills
did better at this question.
Then he gave them
another set of data.
And this time he
said this set of data
is looking at
whether gun control
laws are reducing crime.
Look at the data,
analyze the data,
and tell me whether
gun control rules
are helping in reducing crime.
Now, the difference
here is that everyone
had very strong opinions
about gun control laws.
Some people were for, and
some people were against.
And that interfered with their
ability to analyze the data.
And, in fact, those with
better math skills did worse.
Because they were
using their skills
not necessarily to find
the accurate conclusion,
but rather to find
fault with the numbers
that they were unhappy with.
Right, they had the skills to
do so, while the others didn't.
AUDIENCE: Did everyone get
the same report in data?
TALI SHAROT: Yes.
So actually it
was the same data.
AUDIENCE: Then isn't it
possible that it just
happens to be that the
people with high math skills
happen to have the
political opinions that
disagreed with that data?
TALI SHAROT: No.
So it was a two by two design.
AUDIENCE: So there was
different sets of data.
TALI SHAROT: Yeah.
Yeah.
It was a two by two
design, which is sometimes
the data would agree
with one opinion,
and sometimes with
the other opinion.
And everything was
counterbalanced.
Yeah.
Good question, though.
OK.
So the next question
is why would we
have a brain that has
evolved to disregard
perfectly good information
when it doesn't fit our view?
So the answer is that
the brain assesses
a piece of new evidence
in light of the knowledge
that it already stores
because on average that is,
in fact, the correct approach.
So, for example, if
I were to tell you
that I saw a pink elephant
flying in the sky,
you would assume that I am lying
or delusional, as you should.
Because on average when
a piece of evidence
doesn't fit a belief that
you hold strongly, on average
that piece of evidence is wrong.
So it's a shortcut
that the brain
uses to assess evidence and
incorporate into beliefs, which
it actually is quite optimal.
It's a good process.
However, it also means
that strongly held beliefs
are very difficult to change,
even when they're wrong.
There are four
factors that determine
whether a piece of evidence
will change your belief.
Your current belief, your
confidence in that belief,
the new piece of evidence,
and the confidence
in that piece of evidence.
And now the further the piece
of evidence is from your belief,
the less likely it
is to change it.
There is one exception though.
And that is when the
piece of evidence
doesn't fit what
you believe, but it
fits what you want to believe.
So let me give you an example.
So a few months before the
presidential election 1,000
Americans were asked by a
group of scientists in England,
who do you want to
win the election,
and who do you think is
going to win the election?
So back in August 2016
50% wanted Trump to win
and 50% wanted Clinton to win.
But back then the
Trump supporters
and the Clinton
supporters believed
that Clinton was going to win.
Then they were given a new poll.
And that poll predicted
a Trump victory.
And they were asked
again, OK, now
that you've seen the poll, who
do you think is going to win?
Did it change their prediction?
And the answer was, yes.
It changed their predictions.
But mostly it changed
the predictions
of the Trump supporters.
They were elated
by this new poll.
And they were quick to move
and say, well, in that case,
maybe he's going to win.
The Clinton supporters,
on the other hand,
didn't change their
prediction much.
They said, well, we still
think Clinton is going to win.
We don't really
believe this poll.
So when people encounter
a piece of evidence
that goes against what
they really want to believe
and what they want to happen
our immediate reaction
is basically this,
denial, rationalization,
and trying to just distance
ourselves from the fact.
And perhaps the
most efficient way
to distance ourself from
the truth or from the facts
is not to expose ourselves
to that information
in the first place.
So take, for example,
the stock market.
You know when people
check their account
to see how much they are worth?
So not with any intention
to make a transaction.
Just to have a little peek to
see have my stocks gone up?
Have they gone down?
So this is a study conducted
by three behavioral economists,
Lowenstein, Sepi, and Carlson.
And what you can
see here in black
is the S&P 500 over two years.
And in gray is a number of
times that people logged in
to check on their accounts.
Now, these are not raw numbers.
So they've been corrected for
all the obvious confounds,
like market volume, and
willingness to transact,
and all of that.
OK.
So what do we think?
When the market is high people
tend to log in all the time.
They say, well, when the market
is high my value probably
has gone up.
And they want to get a
sniff of the good news.
But when the market
is down people
are less likely to log in.
They say, well,
the market is down.
I probably lost money,
and I don't want to know.
Now, all this is true as
long as negative information
can reasonably be avoided.
So what you don't
see here is what
happened a few months later in
the financial collapse of 2008
when the market went
drastically down,
and that's when people started
logging on frantically.
But it was a little
bit too late.
So we know a little
bit about the biology
that underlies this behavior.
And a lot of what we know
actually comes from monkeys.
So there is a great series of
studies by Ethan [INAUDIBLE]
Martin at Columbia University.
And what Ethan showed
is that monkeys too
want to know about the
good stuff ahead of time.
So what Ethan did
is he did a study
where monkeys could
get a big reward, which
was a lot of water, or they
can get a small reward, which
is a little water.
Now, for monkeys water
was really important.
They were quite thirsty.
So this was a big deal for them.
It's kind of like getting
$1,000 versus $10.
And he asked the
monkeys, do you want
to know a few seconds in
advance whether you're
going to get a lot of water
or a little bit of water?
Now, the monkeys
can't talk obviously.
But he trained them
over many weeks
to know what different
symbols mean.
So one symbol they
knew if you see
the symbol I will tell you in
advance how much water you're
going to get.
If you see this other symbol
I will not let you know.
And so the monkeys use
their eyes to indicate
do I want to know or
do I not want to know?
And then if they
said, I want to know,
then he showed another symbol.
And that symbol said, you're
about to get a lot of water.
Or he showed another
symbol that said,
you're going to get a
little bit of water.
So first thing he found is,
yes, the monkeys want to know.
Just as we want to know
if we got a lot of money,
the monkeys want
to know that too.
The second thing
was they were even
willing to pay to know a few
seconds in advance how much
water they were going to get.
The way that they paid
is they paid by water.
So they would give up
a little bit of water
to know a few seconds in
advance how much water they
were going to get.
And Ethan did more than that.
He recorded the brain
activity of the monkeys
while they were making
these decisions.
So he inserted electrodes
into the monkey's brains,
specifically to a part of the
brain called the midbrain where
there is dopaminergic neurons.
And those neurons are
known to respond to rewards
like water, food, sex.
And he recorded those neurons.
And what he wanted to know
is, do those neurons respond
not only to your basic
rewards, like food and water,
do they also respond
to the opportunity
to receive information?
Right.
He was asking, does the
brain treat information
as if it's a real reward?
So let me show you his results.
It's a bit of a
complicated graph,
but I'll walk you through it.
So what we're looking
at here is activity
of these dopaminergic
neurons in the midbrain.
And the first thing that you
see is the classic finding
which is there is great
activity at the moment when
the monkeys receive a large
reward into their mouth, lots
of water.
And there is a decrease when
they receive just a little bit.
So they're disappointed.
So basically these neurons
go up when things are good,
and they go down
when things are bad.
OK.
Now the important thing.
He found that the same
exact neurons also
fire when the monkey learns that
he's about to get information.
Kind of like you get an
email or you get an envelope.
You don't know what's
in it yet, but you
know there's information.
The neurons fire
to the opportunity
to receive information, just
as they do to water and food.
And when the monkeys
learn I'm not
going to give you information
there is a decrease in firing.
So they go down.
They're disappointed.
So Ethan's conclusion was, yes,
the brain treats information
as if information is
rewards, like water and food.
But when I saw that
I asked Ethan, well,
is this true for any
kind of information,
or is it only true
for information
about the good stuff?
What happens if the
monkey's not getting water.
It's getting shocks,
electric shocks.
Does a monkey want
to know in advance
if it's going to be a big
shock or a small shock?
So Ethan said, well, I
can't shock my monkeys,
because the ethics won't
allow me to do that.
So he said, well, let's do
it on undergrads in my lab.
[LAUGHTER]
And actually we can get
ethics to shock undergrads,
but we decided there's no need.
And we just use a design where
they either get a lot of money
or a little bit of money,
or they lose a lot of money
or lose a little bit of money.
And what we found
was, first of all,
the undergrads looked
a lot like monkeys.
So they wanted to
know in advance
whether they're going
to get a lot of money
or a little bit of money.
They were even willing to
pay us a little bit for that.
And, yes, when we recorded
the same region that Ethan
was looking at in monkeys--
we recorded that in
undergrads using FMRI--
we found the same response.
So when they learned they
were about to get information
about good stuff,
these neurons went up.
And when they learned we're not
going to tell you in advance,
they went down.
And when it came to losses we
found the opposite pattern.
So when they
learned that they're
going to get
information about losses
there was actually a decrease
in firing, a disappointment.
But when they learned
we're not going to tell you
about how much
you're going to lose
there was actually an
increase in firing,
as if the brain was
treating ignorance
as a reward when the ignorance
was about the bad stuff.
And behaviorally the
undergrads, the more
they were likely to win, the
more they wanted to know.
But the more they
were likely to lose,
the less they wanted to know.
And so this kind of explains
our everyday behavior.
We want to know the good stuff.
Did I get the job?
How much money did I get?
But we kind of don't
want to go to the doctor
to hear about our results.
And when we expect a
bad email coming our way
we don't check
our phone so much.
But when we expect something
good, then we check it a lot.
So if the brain
treats information
about the good stuff
like food and water,
and it treats information
about bad stuff like a shock,
well, it's not
surprising that we
try to find information
about the good stuff
and try to avoid information
about the bad stuff,
just as we do trying
to avoid shocks
and trying to get
food and water.
And so we will end up with a
view like this of ourselves.
Now, our mistake is that
instead of going along
with how our brain works we
often try to go against it.
We often try to put a clear
mirror in front of people
and say, look, this
is how it looks.
This is the data.
Things are going to get worse.
Or you're wrong and I'm right.
And it doesn't often work,
because the brain will
try to frantically distort
the information until it
gets the picture
that it's happy with.
But what will happen if we went
along with how our brain works,
not against it?
And that's the idea of
"The Influential Mind."
Basically what I do
in "The Influential
Mind," in each chapter
I talk about one
of these factors that are really
important for how people form
beliefs and decisions, whether
it's a confirmation bias,
or how we seek information,
or other factors.
And then I say,
well, given that we
know that, how can we go along
with that to make a change?
And what kind of
mistakes do we do
when we try to go against
this way that our brain works?
So I'm just going to
give you a few examples.
I'm just going to
look at that time
to make sure that we have time
for questions and everything.
So I'm going to give you a few
examples of how we can do that.
So the first thing
I talked about
was how the brain encodes
information much better when it
comes from an agreeing partner.
So our mistake is that usually
when we're in a disagreement
we come with counter
evidence, right.
It's like, you're
wrong, I'm right.
Here is all the evidence.
And it doesn't
often work so well.
But could we go along
with how our brain works?
Could we go along with
a confirmation bias
by first trying to
find common grounds?
So common beliefs
or a common motive
so the other person is more
likely to kind of encode
what we're saying.
And let me give you one example
of how this has been done.
So this is an example that
relates to the relationship
between autism and vaccines.
So some parents decide not
to vaccinate their kids
because of the alleged link
between autism and vaccines.
Now, the normal approach
of health professionals
is to say, well, here's
all the data showing
that there isn't a link.
But when people have
a very strong opinion,
that doesn't seem to work.
And there's studies
showing that there's really
no change in people's
attitudes when they learn
this, or a very small change.
But then a group
at UCLA said, well,
can we take a different route?
Can we get to the
same outcome, which
is getting the parents
to vaccinate their kids,
without actually talking
about what we disagree on,
but rather talking
about what we agree on?
And so what they
highlighted instead
was that these vaccines
actually protect kids
from the measles,
mumps, or rubella.
This is not something that
the parents disagreed on.
But it seemed to be forgotten
in the heated debate.
So by highlighting, in fact,
what they agreed on, and also
a common motive
that they had, which
is keeping the
kids healthy, they
were able to change parents'
intentions of vaccinating
their kids by three-fold.
So trying to think about what
we have in common in order
to kind of work with
a confirmation bias
instead of against it.
And there's another reason
that this works so well.
And that relates to
the brain's tendency
to encode information
that suggests
progress better than information
that suggests decline.
So let me first show
you an experiment
that we've done that shows
this and then how can we
use that knowledge.
So in one study we brought
people into the lab,
and we gave them 100
different events,
negative events that can happen
to them in their lifetime.
For example, cancer.
And we said, what
is the likelihood,
do you think, that
you will encounter
this event in your lifetime?
Just put in the number.
So each person
puts in the number.
And then we say, well,
this is the likelihood
that you will have
cancer based on your age,
and where you live, and
the gender, and so on.
Its about, for
example, 30%, which
is actually close to the
number in the population.
And then we asked them again.
How likely are you
to have cancer,
and 100 different other events.
What we wanted to know is
whether the information
that we gave them
changed their estimates.
And what we found is,
indeed, it did, but mostly
when the information was
better than expected.
So, for example,
if someone said,
well, I think my likelihood
of having cancer is about 50%,
and we said, hey,
for someone like you
it's only about 30%,
it's good news, right?
So they said, well, in that
case, maybe it's only 35%.
So when they got good news they
changed their estimate really
quite quickly.
But if someone
said, well, I think
for me my likelihood
is about 10%,
and we said, for you
it's actually worse.
On average it's
probably around 30%.
The next time around
they said, yeah,
I still think it's about 11%.
So it's not that they didn't
change their estimate at all.
They did.
They learned from bad news.
But they learned from bad
news less than from good news.
And it's not that they didn't
remember the information.
They remembered the
information that we gave them.
But they didn't
think it was related
to them when it was bad news.
But they did think
it was related
to them when it was good news.
And we did this study again
by looking at people's brain
activity while they were
performing this task.
And what we found was that
quite a few regions in the brain
were responsive to unexpected
positive information.
They were encoding this
information quite well,
including this
region here, which
is called the left
inferior frontal gyrus.
So it sits over here.
However, when we
gave people bad news
another part of the
brain on the other side,
the right inferior
frontal gyrus,
was encoding that information.
And on average it didn't
do a very good job.
So it didn't encode it
as well as the good news.
And as a result people were
less likely to incorporate
unexpected bad news than
unexpected good news.
So we were wondering,
can we change this?
Can we change the way that
people process information
by changing the activity
in the brain directly?
And there is at least one
way that we could do that.
And so this is my collaborator.
And what he's doing is, he's
passing a small magnetic pulse
through the scalp
of this participant.
And we can direct
it specifically
to part of the brain.
So we can, for
example, direct it
to the inferior frontal
gyrus that I showed you,
either left or right.
And by doing that
we are interfering
with the activity of
this brain function
for about half an hour.
And after that everything goes
back to normal, or so we hope.
So doing that--
[LAUGHTER]
That was a delayed response.
So during that half
hour we could have
the participant do our tasks.
And we did this for three
groups of participants.
One group was the control group.
So it's as if I would
test all of you now.
And I would measure how
much you learned more
from good news and bad news.
So this is on average how much
you would learn more from good
than bad.
Then we interfered with the
part of the brain that was
encoding negative information.
We interfered with it.
And so the bias
became even larger.
And when we interfered with
the part of the brain that
was encoding good news,
we interfered with it,
the bias disappeared altogether.
So we were kind
of amazed by this,
that we could change this
kind of deep rooted bias
by changing activity
in the brain.
But, of course,
we're not going to go
around zapping people's brains.
And so that means
that on average
when people get bad news--
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Did the interference
reduce people's ability
to learn or increase their
ability to learn correctly?
TALI SHAROT: So, first of
all, it's obviously selective.
Because different parts
interfere with learning either
from good or bad.
And so what is the difference
between learning and learning
correctly?
Can you elaborate?
So overall, it's not a general
interference with learning.
It's valency specific.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
So if you interfere
with the part that
makes them learn very
strongly from good news,
then does that mean that
they learn less strongly
from good news, or that
they learn equally strongly
from good and bad news?
Does it improve the
learning of bad news
or decrease the
learning of good news?
TALI SHAROT: Yeah.
OK.
So that's a very good question.
And so it depends on which
part we were looking at.
So, in fact, the story
is a little bit more
complicated, which is when we
interfered with that part, what
we actually also found was
an inhibition of learning
from bad news.
So the good news
area-- it's not really
a good news area-- but that
part was not only encoding
positive information.
It was also inhibiting learning
from negative information.
And we actually followed this
up with an experiment using DTI.
So DTI basically looks at
white matter connectivity
between different
neuron regions.
And what we could find
was that people who
had better connectivity
between these regions,
the left inferior frontal
gyrus in particularly,
and subcortical regions that
were important for emotion,
and memory, and learning, people
who had better connections
showed more of a bias
because of two things.
Both they learned
better from positive.
And they learned
worse from negative.
So that suggests-- it's only a
suggestion-- that there could
be inhibition, as
well as amplifying
learning from positive, but
also inhibition from negative.
So very good question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
TALI SHAROT: Right.
OK.
So what this means on average--
and also just one little note.
There is individual differences.
So, for example, in depressed
individuals we don't find this.
So they don't have it.
They have the same learning
from positive and negative.
And also hopefully I'll
have time in the end
to show you that actually
this changes according
to your own mental state.
So this is not something
that's stable even
within an individual.
It actually changes
in response to what's
going on in the environment,
and whether you're
in a safe environment or
dangerous environment.
So it's a very flexible system.
But on average, for most people,
in relaxed circumstances,
it means that we
tend to learn more
from the good news
and the bad news.
And so when smokers see
something like this they say,
yes, smoking kills, but
mostly it kills the other guy.
But when they get
the good news, which
is the housing
market is going up,
which it seems to be
going here, people
say, oh, my house will
definitely rise in price.
So what we can
take away from this
is that we often need to reframe
our message to try and figure
out, can I reframe it to
highlight the progress, not
the decline?
And let me give
you a few examples.
And then I'll give you a
more empirical example.
So, for example,
instead of telling a kid
if you smoke you
would get cancer,
you might also say,
well, if you don't
smoke you're more likely to
get on the basketball team.
Or instead of telling
someone if you take out
A you will lose time and
money, so highlighting decline,
you might say if you take route
B you will gain time and money.
So highlighting what we need
to do to get to progress
rather than highlighting what
has been done to decline.
And let me give you one
example, empirical example.
So we all know that
hand-washing is the number one
way to reduce the
spread of disease.
So in a hospital
in the east coast
cameras were installed to see
how often medical staff will
wash their hands before and
after entering a patient's
room.
And the medical staff knew that
the cameras were installed.
It wasn't a nanny
camera situation.
Nonetheless, only 10% of
medical staff, so 1 in 10,
would wash their hands before
and after entering a patient's
room.
But then an electronic
board was introduced.
And the electronic board told
the medical staff in real time
how well they were doing.
So every time the medical
staff washed their hands
there were actually people
in India watching them.
And they automatically
gave them good feedback
on the electronic board.
It said like, well
done, good job.
And also the numbers went
up, showing the current shift
rate and the weekly rate
going up immediately.
And what they found was that
compliance raised to 90%
almost immediately.
And it stayed there.
So this effect is
so large that it
seems a little bit suspicious.
So the research team
made sure to replicate it
in another division
in a hospital.
This time the medical
staff started at 30%.
So one in three medical
staff washed their hands
before and after entering
a patient's room, which is
actually closer to the average.
So the average both in hospitals
and restaurants is 38%.
But then the electronic
board was introduced,
and, again, went up
to 90% immediately.
OK.
So why does this
intervention work so well?
And here is the
general message, right.
It's not about hand-washing.
The reason this
intervention works
so well, one of the
reasons is that instead
of using the normal
approach-- what
would be the normal approach?
The normal approach
in hospitals is
to warn medical
staff of bad stuff
in the future, of
decline, of disease.
Instead of doing that
what they did was
they highlighted the
possibility of progress,
by showing the medical staff
the numbers going up every time
they washed their hands.
And it did one more thing.
It gave the medical
staff immediate rewards.
So every time they
washed their hands
there was a positive feedback.
And we know that positive
feedbacks activate
reward regions in our brains.
There is a reward
signal in our brain
that reinforces the
action that caused it.
And so that action
is more likely to be
repeated in the future.
And that's actually
our next factor
that we're going to talk about,
which is immediate rewards.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You said also
that they're being watched.
Yeah.
Let me get a mic.
It's also that
they're being watched.
I mean, the message is that
they're being monitored.
TALI SHAROT: No.
So we know that's not the case.
Because they were monitored,
and then it was 10%.
So they were monitored.
The first thing they
did was monitor them,
telling them that they
were monitoring them,
and that's where
the 10% came from.
That's the first point, right.
And then they introduced
the electronic board.
And then it went up.
AUDIENCE: Did they try
going, we're watching you,
we're watching you?
TALI SHAROT: I don't know.
I think they just told them
they were going to be watched.
So monitoring alone seemed to
not have much of an effect.
But there are other reasons,
which I talk about in the book.
I just don't have time to
talk about everything today.
But, for example,
social norms come in.
Because what they see is, oh,
look, now 65% of my colleagues
wash their hands.
So it's not only
these two issues.
It's a very smart design because
it really has a lot of things.
There are even other
things that matter here.
It gives them control,
that it's their choice.
So there's other things.
But it's not monitoring.
They knew that.
AUDIENCE: So I've seen a lot
of studies around how pain--
TALI SHAROT: What?
AUDIENCE: Pain, or fear also
motivates more than rewards.
And I haven't really
dug into any of it.
But I'm curious to
hear your thoughts.
TALI SHAROT: Yeah.
So we're going to
talk about it now.
So I'll talk about
when rewards are better
and when fear is better.
So we'll start with the rewards.
So when we talk about
immediate rewards,
both words matter a lot.
So first of all,
immediate and rewards.
So focus about immediate first.
We find that immediate rewards
are more effective than rewards
that you can get in the future
for at least two reasons.
One is known as the
attribution problem.
So imagine your partner
is washing the dishes
and then you give them a kiss.
So it's clear that the kiss is
related to washing the dishes.
And so they're more likely
to wash the dishes again
in the future.
Now, imagine that your
partner is washing the dishes,
but then you give them
a kiss the next day.
It's now not clear
that the kiss is
related to washing the dishes.
And so it's less likely
to strengthen that action.
So immediacy helps
because of that.
And then at least
one other reason
is called temporal discounting.
So we know that
people value rewards
now more than the
same rewards that they
can get in the future.
So, for example,
if you ask people,
do you want $100 now
or $110 next week,
most people will take $100 now.
And at least one reason is
that if you get the money now,
it's certain.
It's in your hands.
But $110 next
week, well, there's
something uncertain about it.
And people don't
want uncertainty.
So that's another reason
why immediate works so well.
Now the question about
rewards versus punishments.
So why are rewards more
likely to induce actions
than punishments, and
when do punishments work?
Well, one reason that
we find that rewards
are more effective
at enhancing action
is because of what's known as
the approach avoidance rule.
So in life to get
the good stuff,
whether it's chocolate cake,
or love, or a promotion,
we usually need to act.
Right.
We need to approach.
We need to do something.
And so our brain has evolved
in an environment where
action is a way to get rewards.
And so our reward system
is very much connected
to our modus system.
And I'm showing you part
of the reward system here.
So down here we
have the midbrain.
So these are the same
neurons that Ethan
recorded from in his monkeys.
So we have dopaminergic neurons
down there in the midbrain.
They go up into the center
of the brain, the striatum,
the nucleus accumbens,
which is what usually people
talk about when they talk about
the reward center in the brain.
And then you go into the
cortex and the motor cortex.
And what we find is that when
you anticipate something good,
a go signal is activated
from the midbrain,
and it makes action more likely.
However, to avoid the
bad stuff in life,
whether it is poison,
or untrustworthy people,
or deep waters, mostly the best
approach is not to do anything,
just to stay put.
Not to take an action.
Not to take a risk.
Not always.
But often that's
the best approach.
And so the brain has
adapted to that environment.
And when people anticipate
a loss or something bad
there is a no go signal in the
brain, and it inhibits action.
So, again, coming from the
midbrain to the motor cortex
and inhibiting action.
A study that was
led by [INAUDIBLE]
that I collaborated on
as well, what he did,
he showed that if
you promise people $1
for pressing a button,
they will be quicker
at pressing the button
than if you tell them
that you will take away $1
for them pressing the button.
So if you say, I'll give you
$1 for pressing the button,
they do it quicker
than if you tell them,
if you press the button I won't
take away $1 from you, a loss.
So they're quicker to do
actions to get a reward.
The opposite happens when
they need to not act.
So when we tell them,
don't press a button
and we will give
you $1, or when you
tell them don't press a
button, and you won't lose $1,
they make less
mistakes when they
don't need to press a button
in order not to lose $1.
The reason, again,
is that when you
tell them don't press a
button to get $1, sometimes
they just immediately press
$1, because the anticipation
of reward causes action.
So that's kind of the connection
between rewards and action
and punishments and inaction.
So back to your
question, it seems
that if you want
to motivate action,
like you wanted to get employees
to work on their report really
well, or if you want your
kid to tidy their room,
perhaps promising a reward
would be better than threatening
with punishment.
But if you want someone
not to do something,
so you want your kid
not to eat a cookie,
or you want your
employees not to share
privileged information, perhaps
the threat of a punishment
would be better.
So we have to be very
cautious from taking
this basic science to more
like real world application.
But if that's true, if
that connection is true,
that's what this suggests.
OK.
So then you can see why
telling the medical staff,
threatening them
that if they need
to wash their hands otherwise
there'll be disease didn't work
as well as promising
them a reward, which
was positive feedback.
And we know, positive feedback,
you can give people money.
That could be a reward.
But these little
likes on Facebook
even work so well, right.
So people go out
of their way just
for a little kind
of like on Facebook,
or a positive feedback.
So those are actually
quite effective.
Let me just make this
last point, which
is a really important
thing for all of this
is to consider the mental state
of the person in front of you.
I already told you that things
are different under depression,
for example.
But they're also different
under different mental states
like stress.
So what we find is that
under stress the brain
function changes
a lot, and the way
that we process information
changes really, really fast.
And people become hyper
vigilant to negative information
around them.
So, for example, in one study
we brought people into our lab,
and we told them, I'm
going to give you a task,
and then I'll give
you a surprise topic.
And you'd have to give a talk
about this surprise topic
in front of everyone.
We're going to judge you.
We're going to record you.
We're going to
put it on YouTube.
So basically what I'm doing
today, but I prepared.
And people got really stressed.
We made sure they were stressed.
We looked at their
cortisol and their saliva.
We looked at the
skin conductance.
So when you stress you
start sweating and your skin
conductance goes up.
We asked them, are you stressed?
Yes, they were stressed.
And then we did
the same experiment
that I showed you earlier where
we give you information that
could be unexpectedly
good or unexpectedly bad,
and we see whether you
incorporate that information
into your beliefs,
like, oh, you're
more likely to
get cancer, you're
less likely to be a victim
of card fraud, and so on.
What we found was that
under stress immediately
people became more
likely to incorporate
negative information
into their beliefs
than they were just
a few seconds ago.
And then at that point
there wasn't a bias, what
we call a desirability bias.
It went away.
They were balanced
in how they took
in the good news
and the bad news.
We did the same experiment
with firefighters
in the state of Colorado.
So the interesting
thing about firefighters
is that their day
can be quite varied.
So some days they're relaxed.
They're in the station.
They're just relaxing.
And some other days are really
life threatening events.
And they did our
studies in the station.
And they had different days.
Some are stressed.
Some are not.
And what we found
was on stressful days
when they were
stressed out they were
more likely to take
in the information
that we gave them that was
negative than on relaxed days.
Although that information had
nothing to do with their job.
It's this general enhancement
of taking in bad news
that stress causes.
It's not a specific.
So you can see how in response
to stressful public events,
like market collapse,
or terrorist attacks,
or natural disaster,
a lot of the stuff
that we had recently causes
people to be stressed.
Even if the event is halfway
around the world people often,
their stress levels go up.
And then what happens
is that people start
getting hyper-vigilant
to negative information
in the media, are more
likely to take it in.
That makes them more
pessimistic, sometimes overly
pessimistic.
And that could cause
suboptimal decisions.
So, for example,
after market collapse
we often find that people
decide to sell stocks
where really the best
thing to do is hold on.
Or after a terrorist
attack people
cancel holidays or decide not to
go on a plane, but go in a car
instead.
Again, suboptimal decisions.
And interestingly,
it changes with age.
So stress changes in a very
predictable manner with age.
So stress is quite low
in kids and teenagers.
It goes up, up, up, reaching
peak in your midlife,
and then starts
going down again.
And happiness goes
the other way.
So happiness is quite high
in kids and teenagers,
down, down, down.
Reaches the bottom in midlife.
But then it starts
going up again.
And that's the good news, right?
So if you're in the slum
now, there's good news.
[LAUGHTER]
And it stays up until the
last couple of years of life.
So let me just end
with this note,
which is what happens if
this is the guy that you're
dealing with?
And actually what you want to
do is reduce stress and increase
happiness?
So one thing to think
about is that our studies
show that the thing that
matters to happiness the most
is not necessarily what's
happening to you now,
but what you expect will
happen to you in the future.
And I'm actually
going to give you
an example from a study
conducted at Harvard where
people were asked a few days
before vacation how happy they
were, a few days during
vacations how happy they were,
and a few days after
vacation how happy they were.
So which day do you think
they were the happiest?
AUDIENCE: Before.
TALI SHAROT: Before.
Right.
So the day they
were still in work,
sitting in their desk, that was
a day that they were happiest,
because in their mind they
were already on vacation.
And in the mind it was perfect.
Then they went on vacation.
It was pretty nice.
But it never was as good
as it was in their mind,
or at least often enough.
So what that means
is that an easy way
to reduce stress and
increase happiness
is to create
anticipatory events.
Always have events that
we could look forward to.
Have that vacation planned.
Have whatever weekend
activities you
like planned, both for
yourself, and for the family,
or for the company.
So employees have things
to look forward to.
OK.
So I think I'm just going to end
here, which is just with kind
of a general note that
most people are not
aware of exactly how
their brain works
and all these
biases that we have.
We're not aware
every day that we're
trying to confirm our
beliefs all the time,
or that stress will
change how you process
any kind of information.
But becoming aware of
it means two things.
A, it means that we might
become more conscious
of our own beliefs
and decisions,
why we have them, why we do it.
And second of all, if we know
how other brains around us
work, we might be better
able to communicate advice
and information to others.
So I think that would be it.
And we might take a
few questions before.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
TALI SHAROT: Thank you so much.
[CLAPPING]
SPEAKER: But we can
ask some questions now
how we could improve decision
making, our own decision
making, and that of others.
So if there are any questions
now in the audience,
please go ahead.
AUDIENCE: From the experiment
where they should not
push the button to not lose $1,
if that was more successful--
but when we put something
on a cigarette pack that
says they're going to
take something from them,
it sounded less
successful than saying,
hey, you can get on the
basketball team instead.
TALI SHAROT: Right.
Right.
That's a very, very good point.
So I think that in
order to quit smoking--
so those warnings are
not too bad for people
who never approached smoking.
The problem with those warnings
are people who already smoke.
That's where we really
don't see much of an effect.
And I've thought about
exactly this question.
And I think that
what is happening
is that in order to quit
smoking you need to take action.
So you actually have to
find alternative things
that you could do,
whether it's gum,
or you have to find
different routines.
And it actually does
include some actions.
So I think that could
be the reason for that.
But yes.
Good observation.
OK.
Well, thank you
so much everyone.
[CLAPPING]